ah c'est ça la surprise
à Trappes donc là on va pouvoir faire un
petit peu de cartes et puis on va vous
apprendre surtout à en faire tous les
thés on va retrouver c'est ça
alors qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
retrouver cet été là aujourd'hui on est
sur la piste compétition au mois d'août
période de vacances donc aussi on a
besoin de partir un petit peu donc on va
rapatrier une partie du matériel utilisé
sur la piste loisir sur la piste
compétition quel âge est requis pour
pouvoir piloter ses cartes alors pour la
partie location donc là nous on commence
on propose du matériel à partir de l'âge
de 8 ans qui correspond aussi à l'âge
proposé au niveau de la fédération pour
la compétition donc on a bien sûr on a
des cartes qui vont être adapter à la
taille des enfants et puis bah après
c'est comme comme on dit de 7 à 77 ans
donc après il y a plus de limite quoi
quand on sent apte et avoir envie de
rouler on pourrait jusqu'à n'importe
quel âge quels sont les consignes de
sécurité à respecter quand on ne connaît
pas du tout le cas alors d'une manière
générale ce qu'il faut c'est toujours
être dans la maîtrise c'est vrai dans
tous les sports donc c'est être dans le
kart et faire des choses qu'on a la
sensation de pouvoir maîtriser d'accord
pour arriver à la cette maîtrise les
petits règles sont simples position des
mains sur le volant à 9h15 pas comme en
voiture on est amené à déplacer les
mains du volant pour tourner puisque là
on est sur un kart vous verrez tout pour
vous essayer une direction directe donc
en un quart de tour de vol en abrakais à
droite ou à gauche au niveau des
commandes les deux pieds sur les pédales
fera accélérateur donc là ça peut être
un petit peu différent de la voiture ou
effectivement du pied droit on freine on
accélère donc des fois si on n'est pas
en maîtrise on peut avoir un mauvais
réflexe au lieu de vouloir freiner on
accélère on y reviendra tout à l'heure
la grosse différence dans le kart c'est
que tu vas être au ras du sol donc là il
faut bien penser là aussi à bien lever
son champ de vision pour chercher
vraiment l'horizon de la piste et
regarder plus loin possible devant soi
parce que là on est à 7 cm
sont à 7 cm de la piste donc le plus
près du sol on va dire risque de se
retourner non quasiment pas
vraiment vraiment poussé dans des dans
un cas extrême notamment parce que
effectivement la législation a nettement
progressé au niveau du matériel du car
ce qui fait que maintenant vous avez vu
vous avez des protections tout autour le
risque qu'il y avait avant c'est quand
il y avait pas ces protections qu'il y
avait un chevauchement de roue qui
pouvait faire que parfois ça arrivait
mais maintenant c'est complètement ça
n'arrive plus du tout question plus
terre à terre ça coûte combien de venir
s'amuser aux cartes pour le mois d'août
ou là on rapatrie tout ici ce qu'on a
décidé c'est de faire un ticket unique
qui va être correspondre à 13 euros donc
voilà le principe pour faire les choses
beaucoup plus simple pendant cette
période
donc c'est la carte qui fait 340 cm3 qui
peut aller à peu près un peu plus de 80
km/h en ligne droite et ben un petit
cabine il nous reste plus qu'à y aller
alors merci
donc là la combinaison
ça rigole pas
procédure pour monter dans le kart tu
avances pied droit directement dans le
baquet voilà tu mets ton pied droit
voilà pour Adrien Joanna dans le bac
mets ton pied dans le bac
aussi voilà tu peux lâcher ton casque
maintenant
sur le dossier voilà tu t'assois et tu
allonges directement tes jambes pour
venir mettre tes pieds en contact sur
les pédales c'est ça les pédales voilà
les pédales
on est plein de ressources
pour l'instant tu touches à rien
elle est concentrée c'est parti
tranquillement
allez c'est parti
c'est
que les garçons
et bien voilà cette séance d'essai est
terminée c'est donc le circuit brka
attrape c'est un très bon circuit il y a
de très et puis il y a Eric qui est très
gentil
parce que je vous avais pas dit c'est
que il y avait une petite surprise ce
que je vous ai pas dit c'est que vous
étiez chronométré car il faut savoir que
chaque séance de location à chaque fois
est chronométrée
j'attendais Johanna tout le temps et
donc à la grande surprise non c'est pas
vrai j'en étais sûr et donc c'est
Johanna qui l'a emporté avec une seconde
d'avance surtout Adrien avec un temps de
50 secondes 270 et pour toi 51 270 mais
c'est pas grave tu reviendras OK et
bravo
bon bah moi je vais aller me changer et
puis bah je vous retrouve tout de suite
à Thoiry en compagnie des animaux voilà
après ce triathlon effréné avec Johanna
j'ai décidé de venir me reposer au
château de Thoiry construit au milieu du
16e siècle il est aujourd'hui le symbole
du zoo animalier qui a pris ses
quartiers en 1968 sous l'impulsion
d'Antoine le comte de La Panouse le père
de Paul l'actuel propriétaire des lieux
alors le château est la propriété de la
famille de Lapanouse depuis 1609 et il a
plutôt bien traversé les événements
historiques puisqu’il regorge d'objets
d'époque alors cet été je vous invite à
visiter le château avec Jenny Jenny
bonjour bonjour Alors là vous êtes en
tenue d'époque du 18e et en plus vous
proposez des visites dans les pièces de
l'époque donc nous visitons toutes les
pièces du rez-de-chaussée qui sont
toutes les pièces de réception qu'on
pouvait avoir à l'époque depuis la
construction du château le comte de
Lapanouse vit encore à l'étage du
château donc bien sûr je ne fais visiter
que le rez-de-chaussée puisque je pense
qui n'apprécierait pas forcément devoir
arriver les visiteurs dans ces partis
privés n'est-ce pas quelle pièce on
pourrait voir quelle pièce sont
disponibles à la visite alors toutes les
pièces du rez-de-chaussée en commençant
par le salon du matin qui est l'unique
pièce qui était réservée pour les gens
du tiers état donc le seigneur de Thoiry
recevait les paysans qui travaillaient
pour lui les gens qui sont domaines vous
avez par exemple aussi le salon vert
dans lequel nous nous trouvons qui est
le plus grand salon du Château qui est
donc le salon d'apparat par excellence
donc dans lequel on recevait les
personnalités illustres telles que vous
par exemple donc là vous êtes un petit
peu dans la peau d'un ministre de
l'époque par exemple un ministre du
XVIIIe siècle
invité très important vous avez de
l'autre côté le salon qu'on appelle de
la tapisserie qui était une salle à
manger et donc qui porte son nom parce
qu'il comporte une tapisserie qui a été
offerte par Louis XVI à un habitant du
château donc c'est pour ça on montre la
très très belle tapisserie cadeau royal
de Louis XVI alors il y avait aussi une
chaise en particulier dans cette salle à
manger avec une histoire relativement
mignonne quand même oui c'est vrai donc
ici a vécu Jean-Baptiste de macho qui
était donc ministre de Louis XV et donc
ce monsieur qui avait vécu ici à qui
d'ailleurs a été offerte la belle
tapisserie de cette pièce a fait faire
donc une petite chaise une chaise
réhaussée pour son petit-fils pour qu'il
puisse prendre donc les repas à table
avec ses parents avec sa famille sans se
retrouver donc avec le menton sur la
table donc une chaise avec un coussin un
peu plus haut que les autres chaises et
derrière laquelle donc il a fait mettre
les initiales donc pour que le petit
garçon puisse reconnaître sa chaise la
visite du château est maintenant
terminée et je vous propose tout de
suite sans plus attendre de partir à la
rencontre de ces animaux qui peuplent le
parc
quelle est la particularité de cette
partie du réserve donc là on est dans la
partie safari c'est à dire que nous on
est dans nos véhicules et les animaux
sont en liberté autour de nous là on est
dans la partie qui fait à peu près 40 50
hectares et donc toutes les antilopes
sont mélangées libres de se déplacer au
gré de leurs envies là on a un beau
groupe de boeufs watussi
mélangé derrière avec un oryx paysa de
l'autre côté vous avez les dromadaires
toutes ces espèces peuvent se déplacer
dans la journée c'est pour ça que on
peut tomber sur des gros rassemblements
de troupeaux puis des endroits où il y
en a un petit peu moins donc faut pas
hésiter à faire plusieurs tours on peut
faire deux tours de suite pour essayer
de voir les animaux qu'on aurait raté au
premier passage
alors là on est dans une partie plutôt
africaine puisqu'on a des éléphants
d'Afrique et des girafes un peu plus
africaine on essaye plus possible
évidemment de respecter les origines des
animaux pour pas faire des mélanges un
peu incohérents donc là et les fonds
d'Afrique les girafes toutes les
antilopes comme les gnous les cobes à
croissants juste ici sont tous des
animaux d'origine africaine
alors là Christophe c'est une situation
particulière on s'est arrêté mais ça
n'est pas conseillé c'est peut-être même
interdit même fortement déconseillé et
carrément interdit donc là nous on est
sorti il est absolument interdit de
sortir de sa voiture évidemment là nous
on est en sécurité on sait ce qui se
passe mais on peut avoir des espèces un
peu plus dangereuses avec des cornes des
antilopes d'une autre ruche pas d'accord
donc voilà dans les voitures c'est la
règle donc on est avec un expert il ne
faut surtout pas le faire quand vous
venez visiter la réserve de Thoiry voilà
alors Christophe la visite et maintenant
terminée la visite de la réserve parce
que maintenant nous allons à la
rencontre des animaux des espèces qui
sont dans le parc donc en cage on va
peut-être voir des lions maintenant là
on va aller voir les lieux en priorité
allons-y alors
petite précision apportée Christophe
concernant les lions si on veut avoir
une grande chance de les voir il faut
venir à certaines heures voilà vous avez
pu vous les voyez normalement assez bien
mais au cours de l'après-midi vers 15h à
15h même précise on fait une petite
animation au niveau du tunnel donc on
donne un petit peu de nourriture au lion
évidemment vous avez la chance d'avoir
les lions vraiment très très près de
vous avec même certains sur le tunnel et
là vous vous rendez vraiment compte de
la taille d'un lion et de la puissance
que peut avoir un lion vous avez vu même
pas peur
alors là on est devant un enclos de
macaque il y a près de 70 80 individus
comment on fait pour réguler autant de
d'animaux alors on a des moyens de
régulation quelques femelles sont
castrés stérilisés dans ce dans ce
groupe là et puis après on a aussi une
régulation qui se fait un petit peu
naturellement entre les naissances et
les décès naturels des animaux un peu
plus âgés ou un peu malade on arrive à
avoir en permanence une une soixantaine
70 animaux voilà des années
et en fait il faut faire attention parce
que quand vous mettez les arbres comme
ça par exemple entre les îles vous êtes
obligé de respecter une certaine
distance mais qui saute
mais on fait ça aussi par un pour un
félin on fait l'un comme une panthère
qui monte un arbre il faut évidemment
que il n'est pas des jonctions d'arbres
entre de branches entre arbres intérieur
et arbres extérieur
évidemment donc là les tous les arbres
voilà on fait attention que les branches
ne soient pas
plongeantes dans l'enclos depuis
l'extérieur par exemple
la procédure
il va sortir sa langue c'est par sa
langue qui sent c'est par un salon qui
prospecte et qui ramène des particules
au niveau de la bouche donc c'est là qui
sont voilà qui est en train de sentir
que ça c'est pas de la nourriture ça se
mange pas souhaitez-vous bonne chance
on est sur des varans du commodo c'est
unique en France ou en Europe c'est pas
unique en Europe c'est unique en France
en Europe il y a quelque part qui
présentent les varans de Komodo mais
c'est une espèce rarissime en captivité
et donc quelle est la particularité du
varan de Komodo il n'a pas de prédateur
sur son île d'origine voilà c'est une
espèce qui vient d'Indonésie sur les
îles de Komodo et quelques îles autour
et c'est le super prédateur de son
milieu c'est à dire qu'il y a pas de
prédateurs au-dessus de lui donc il est
au sommet de sa chaîne alimentaire et
donc il est capable de chasser des
proies comme des serres des sangliers
donc des proies assez importantes c'est
rassurant ce que vous nous dites il y a
aucun risque là pour nous d'être juste à
quelques centimètres
ici voilà et bien Christophe merci
beaucoup pour toute la vie
grâce à Christophe on a appris beaucoup
de choses sur le parc il ne reste plus
qu'à vous de le découvrir alors la
visite c'est de 11h à 19h pour le
château pour le parc c'est le 10h à 18h
c'est ouvert tous les thés pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez consulter le
numéro qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran ou consultez le site Internet de
Thoiry
www.toiries.net il ne me reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter de bonnes vacances vous
faire tout plein de bisous et en
profiter beaucoup tout l'été du soleil
on espère qu'il va être
comment
dire
bonjour à tous bien sûr